the problem is like why nobody is
thinking like what's in it for the gamer
the approach right now is we just have
exclusives you have to use our platform
that's it that's kind of sad
that's what pushed us to the idea of a
galaxy yeah yes yeah
GOG is the PC game platform you might
know and love for its anti DRM stance
it's a consumer friendly policy that's
the exception to the rule
cogs goodwill towards customers got its
foot in the door but the pressures of
competition from the likes of the epic
store and steam are no doubt hurdles to
overcome the trick to getting over these
obstacles and ensuring growth for GOG
may lie in the upcoming launch of Galaxy
2.0 which doesn't merely overhaul the
look of the platform's desktop client
but expands its functionality in a bid
to offer even more services and
conveniences to users we recently sat
down with God's managing director Peter
Karofsky and senior vice president of
business development
Olek Lepofsky to discuss their vision
and the ongoing development of GOG
galaxy 2.0 so when you launch your
galaxy 2.0 for the first time you can
connect any existing platform that you
are also playing with and playing on and
once you do that which is basically a
very simple process you just log in but
that platform maybe use Authenticator
you have to confirm that but once you
just login once a connection is
established and all your games and all
your friends are automatically synced
into GOG galaxy so for games this means
that you will see all the games as one
master collection you will be able to
launch them install them from any PC
platform as your stats and your
activities and for friends it means well
obviously seeing all the friends in one
place seeing what they're playing
seeing their stats as well so you can
compare them compare yourself against
them and our vision for this ultimately
is to be like one master friends list of
all your friends and also having the
ability to chat with those friends but
not just GOG galaxy - GOG galaxy it's
GOG galaxy to those platforms so if I
see my friend playing on a console I can
send a message and he will receive the
message on the console as well that's
the general vision would have obviously
many things will depend on how platform
holder is sortie launcher holders
will perceive it how they will be
supporting us how they will be open to
talk about it like we started
discussions I think with majority of the
guys right now discussions are moving
quite good definitely after announcement
I'm sure it will speed up but whether
it's going to happen or not I'm sure
that community will always be willing to
develop it further yeah so also one of
the one of the things that was kind of a
core of our idea for creating those
integrations with different platforms is
that we want this whole system to be
absolutely open-source so together with
the launch of GOG galaxy will offer all
the users worldwide to create their own
integrations with any platforms they
wish with any features that this
platform offers and build it into GOG
galaxy to extend it not just to maybe
different platforms but maybe even two
features that we haven't thought of my
personal dream and I think a lot of
people at GE share this as well is you
know we would be very happy for any and
every client in the world to actually
offer the same so if you know beyond
just you know agreeing with one or other
company that we want to integrate in on
their platform to GOG will be super
happy actually if all of those companies
would be able to also integrate the same
idea of having all the games and all the
friends in one place and you know if we
could end with with a world where every
client no matter which you use shows you
the same friends this on PC from all the
platforms allows you to charge cross
pass from this will be amazing for me as
a PC gamer
I think that's something that had
actually in mind and subject we were
discussing when we were coming up with
the idea of go galaxy 2.0 that's what we
saw that there are many games appearing
with their own clients with their own
launchers also the industry was changing
because there were more and more game
the services appearing that also created
their own ecosystems their own
environments and then we were thinking
how many clients we have installed on
our computers nowadays but at the same
time sometimes you tend to forget and
actually this is my problem what my
friends are playing right now and where
I have this or that friend do I have
this friend on GOG do I have this friend
on Steam or on battlenet and if I want
to spend time with them I need to
constantly launch all these applications
trying to find hey where these guys or
using third-party applications to chat
with them talk to them etcetera so the
market becomes super fragmented well
maybe it's also a change in the business
model because in the past generally
everybody was scheming about sales it's
not only about sales it's about direct
relationship with your customer with
your clients with gamer and in order to
understand what their needs are you need
to be able to contact them without any
middleman and from this perspective
clearly understand why so many
developers and publishers are trying to
build their own clients launchers it's
probably proper development of the
industry the main thing we shouldn't
forget the dog image yes exactly what
you what you're saying is I absolutely
get the fragmentation I absolutely
understand where is it coming from
business-wise but the the problem is
like why nobody is thinking like what's
in it for the gamer like how can we like
you build a platform that's that's
really great you have an exclusive there
that's cool but why should the user use
this platform like what is better about
this platform than is better than then
steam offers like and sadly I think this
part is being very heavy like ignored
the approach right now is we just have
exclusives you have to use our platform
in that's it that's kind of sad that's
what pushed us to the idea of a galaxy
yeah so privacy is absolutely crucial
topic for us when like GOG Isis all the
games and friends in one place but
internally when we work of it we
actually have three pillars it's games
friends and privacy and our approach is
to basically design the whole thing with
privacy in mind so first and foremost
when you use GOG Galax we're not doing
anything fish in your computer we're not
spying we're not doing any telemetry of
what apps do you have installed how do
you use your computer do you have this
client or that client we we don't care
about this stuff we're not in a data
business user data business so this is
the thing number one the thing number
two is yes we have once you connect the
platform we of course upload this data
to the server so you can access it from
any other device from any other computer
that you're using but that doesn't mean
we are you know just free to do anything
with this data this is your data and
we're very strict to have the approach
where we're not doing anything with it
that we're not going to transfer
anything to any third party site or
anything again we're not in a business
of selling user data so probably no
spying your data belongs to you and when
I'm going to share this data with any
third party we make it really easy for
your right to connect any platform with
GOG galaxy 2.0 but in the same way it's
very easy to remove that platform
connection from GOG galaxy 2.0 and this
means that once you disconnect the
platform the data you import it to our
servers is automatically removed from
our servers and it's you can connect
with one click and in this connect with
one click so actually removing that data
it's very easy and we do it on purpose
because first of all it's your data as
you said the data belongs to you but at
the same time for us this is a way to
set the bar really high for us because
the only reason for you to keep the data
is that because the app is so good that
you want to keep on using it
[Music]
business is something that comes seconds
after us making sure there is it's a
good application it's a good client
something that gamers are going to use
you gamers are going to use it we have
plenty of games and services within our
group that we can propose the gamers if
they are interested in those and I think
that's the main direction when it comes
to monetization what usually bothers me
when when people talk monetization is
that very often business looks at people
as a kind of wallets with with lies like
like that the customer is just you know
and walking wallet and you know as all
excel like we we make money first as the
part of the CDP group so they probably
grow with the games that we sell we make
money as a GOG also the games that we
sell the drm-free titles and our
approach is like absolutely like we hope
that you will love the app that we're
creating so much the services the games
that we build that you will just vote
with your wallet and that's how we'll
make money somebody will be willing to
buy a copy of cyberpunk for months or if
somebody will be willing to spend some
time and money in went will appreciate
it but again it should be gamers
decision and not us forcing something
so relativism now a very soon like we
want this to be absolutely the best so
this is always a tough question like
when so right now we're launching
signups for the for the closed beta and
I think we might have some surprises
just after e3 that yeah I think
definitely we can say summer that's when
we plan to launch close better more
dates after it fee
[Music]
you